was geht ab liebe leute willkommen
zurück bei isar germany bei uns ist
heute corner von language tal
hallo connor haben die iren du kommst ja
aus irland wir haben die iren eigentlich
auch so einen starken humor wie die
engländer oder eher so wie die deutschen
wo ich glaube sie sind dies mehr wie die
engländer aber ein bisschen anders das
ist wahr
aber wir glauben dass wir ein bisschen
lustiger
ok also connor und ich wir werden heute
mal rausfinden wie deutsche reagieren
und zwar auf witze über deutsche wir
haben euch vor ein paar wochen gefragt
schickt uns eure besten witze und die
besten liest kann er jetzt vor
für die leute auf der straße los geht's
[Musik]
german arrives at the end of custom so
fischer erste aktion
wir können darüber lachen
das finde ich wirklich gut bin
[Gelächter]
situationskomik eigentlich nichts mehr
da was nicht stimmt tatsächlich keinen
einzigen kann einfach nicht lachen kann
ich so nicht so richtig sie hasst lachen
wie du mache ich das nie warum weiß
nicht ich das immer nur so weiß wer hat
er gefragt hat keiner kriegt man nicht
so schnell zum lachen
es muss da glaube ich schon ein bisschen
klavier sind da ein bisschen der war
drauf als ja ich fand das schon ziemlich
harmlos jetzt mehr
ich glaube witze über deutsch ist nur so
mittel witzig warum es jetzt ein wie
viele deutsche braucht man um eine
glühbirne auszuwechseln
viele bestimmte drei einer der arbeitet
einer der zukunft und einer der die
anweisungen gibt
ich glaube drei oder einen rasierer
heraus schraubten der sehen wir
einpacken alter sie fest macht oder wie
so was habe ich mal gehört aber ich kann
mich nicht erinnern einen deutschen sind
effizient und haben keinen humor ich
glaube den kann ich sogar schon nein
fand ich besser einmal wie effizient
sind und keinen humor haben
wer wird es so lane den kannte der schon
ja ich meine sind hat diese typischen
vorurteile vom deutschen dass wir strikt
sind das hier keinen humor haben dass
ihr alles genau nehmen und pünktlich
sind und arbeiten
erschreckenderweise ist es teilweise
wirklich so wir haben davon kommt ja
auch teilweise unser guter ruf im
ausland dass wir halt so verlässlich
sind und gute arbeit leisten und
pünktlich sind deswegen werdet ihr alle
deutsch-kanadier reist der hat die ganze
zeit was heißt ja ja ja und du kennst
sehr viele verschiedene menschen und
sprichst zehn verschiedene sprach ja das
ist wahr
mehr als zehn spannungsfeld ja ich kann
jetzt nichts sagen das ist 12 wurde 13
oder einiger also du kennt sehr viel
sprachen sehr viele länder was ist das
land mit den meisten humor gegen muss
sagen vielleicht großbritannien oder
irland
wolf wir bauen jetzt ja alles nicht
überraschen nein also deutschland ist es
auf jeden fall nicht absolut nichts was
ist der unterschied zwischen deutschland
und österreich
nein es gibt keinen wirklichen
unterschied
wie können besser kochen
die einen erzählen jetzt fällt mir doch
was ist der unterschied zwischen
deutschland und österreich
keine ahnung
deutschland hat einen netten nachbarn
[Gelächter]
den finde ich witzig finde ich gut denn
merke ich mir auch auf jeden fall den
werde ich weiter erzählen
okay nicht so witzig gemeint in
österreich nicht so cool österreich gibt
es ganz viele dumme menschen aber gott
sei dank waren die alle nach den ferien
wieder nach deutschland und zwar den
matthias mutter hat uns den geschickt
und da geht so in österreich gibt es
ganz schön viele dumme menschen aber
gottseidank fahren die nach den ferien
alle wieder nach hause nach deutschland
nicht so gut da wie auch in anderen
humor kann sein wenn sie denn wird zu
über österreich ich habe die haben
mehrere zu über uns ich hab mir jetzt
also hast du noch unklar
ja und da gab es so einen alle glauben
immer hinter ist deutscher und der dem
walzer erfunden hat der österreicher
dann ist es genau andersrum
das ist kein witz oder
ja warum hat frankreich so viele straßen
mit bäumen
warum die frau in frankreich sind die
bäume haben mit bäumen ja
ich weiß es schon wieder nicht
naja ich kann mir schon vorstellen wenn
er viele leute aufhängen kann oder was
sind die priester wenn sie sich
verstecken können wir bekommen damit die
französische hochklettern können wir die
deutschen kommen weil wir die deutsche
gerne im schatten rascheren ok
marschieren fand ich meine variante weil
die deutschen gerne im schatten
marschieren mit dem massieren ja wenn er
von anfang macht das ist immer besser
also man kann auch witze machen heute
deutsche können über nazi witze lachen
ja oder nein ich ja aber ich behaupte
auch dass ich keinen durchschnittlichen
deutschen humor habe sondern
wahrscheinlich eher einen
internationaleren darum kann ich drüber
lachen ich glaube der allgemeine
deutsche was nicht lustig er fühlt sich
dann sehr schnell angegriffen attackiert
ich persönlich finde sehr sehr witzig
ich mag nazi witze und ich kann auch
über deutschland über mich selber lachen
[Gelächter]
was ist das kürzeste buch der welt dass
witze buch der deutschen
ich glaube ja liebe leute das war's
schon wieder für heute ihr habt gesehen
wir haben die besten witze voll gewesen
die ihr uns geschickt habe die deutschen
haben sehr unterschiedlich darauf
reagiert also das geht noch besser
vielleicht schickt wir uns einfach noch
bessere witze und dann lesen wir noch
mal den weg wie zuvor
das auch einen kanal oder ja ich habe
ein kanal auf youtube über spargel zu
lernen und war vor besser reisen ja so
bin immer unterwegs sie ich bin sehr oft
in osteuropa
in der ukraine rumänien russland
weißrussland in dieser länder und auch
ein bisschen in brasilien ja viele
videos da liegt immer fitter aber dann
schaut mal rein bei languages zahl also
das werdet ihr jetzt hier eingeblendet
bekommt und wir möchten mehr witze von
euch haben
ansonsten ist im skript wie sie german
werdet ein patch in und bis zur nächsten
woche